on soit 10 mailhiot bonjour et merci
d'être en direct sur rt france alors le
rebond économique de la chine semble se
confirmer
peut-elle profite profiter pardon de la
crise sanitaire pour accroître sa
domination économique sur la planète
selon vous où il fait une domination
dépendantes c'est à dire que s'il reste
de la planète ne marche pas
la chine va trouver très vite des
limites à son rebond donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'elle a fait c'est qu'elle a remis en
route la machine productive elle a
encore remis en route la machine à créer
du service on sait que la chine cherche
à s'orienter au maximum vers les
services vers tout ce qui est soft alors
que c'était avant tout une machine
exportatrice de bien elle ne se
réorienter le rebond est lié à la remise
en route de l'industrie manufacturière
il ya encore beaucoup de choses à faire
pour à la fois reprendre le cours qui
était celui qui avait été entamé avant
l'épidémie
et puis concerné ce que vous appelez
cette nomination parce qu'une domination
ça veut dire des échanges et les
échanges aujourd'hui ils sont
considérablement ralenti du fait des
problèmes logistiques
mais quand finement et puis bien sûr des
difficultés à importer d'un certain
nombre de pays tout simplement parce que
c'est une paix économique qu'ils
traversent
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
finalement la chine a bien réussi à
gérer cette crise sanitaire
le confinement le déconfinement et on en
voit justement les répercussions sur
l'économie comme la coupe hors des pays
asiatiques
de façon générale mais avec une méthode
qui a été employé on peut dire que la
chine effectivement avait vu les lacets
sanitaire de l'actrice tout l'arc
asiatiques qui va de la corée jusqu'au
vietnam et même probablement jusqu'en
thaïlande à juguler la crise certains
avec un processus de responsabilisation
des citoyens membres d'une démocratie
active et participative c'est le cas de
la corée de taïwan
certains de façon autoritaire comme le
vietnam et la chine
le résultat est là quoi qu'il arrive et
il est naturellement très différent de
celui de la majeure partie des pays
occidentaux donc du poids du sony tard
oui la crise a été surmontée de façon je
dirais dirigiste il n'y a pas de rebond
il n'y à vivre non pas deuxième vague
est ce que les chiffres sont exactement
ce que l'on a annoncé peut-être quand il
supérieur mais comme son et en chine ces
temps ci on voit très peu de masques et
on a des systèmes de codage qui font
qu'on peut circuler de façon quasi libre
ou en tout cas aussi libre que possible
dans une file que l'on connaît alors
selon le fonds monétaire international
la chine contribuera pour 51% de la
reprise économique mondiale pour les
années 2020 2021
quand les etats unis eux n'y
contribueront qu'à hauteur de 3%
est-ce qu'on assiste ici un passage de
témoin du leadership mondial entre ces
deux puissances
les films sur dix est limpide mondiale
quoi qu'il arrive et là encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire pour rattraper les
états unis qui sont environ 30%
au-dessus de son pipe en terme nominal
en termes de pipe habitants bien
évidemment la chine étant à 20% du pib
des pays développés
donc bien sûr la chine pays le plus
peuplé du monde 1 milliard 400 millions
d'habitants elle a une vocation je
dirais à être un des acteurs importants
de l'économie mondiale l'occasion
peut-être aussi être le numéro 1 et ne
veut nous faire croire qu'elle n'est que
forte
les très fortes mais elle a aussi
beaucoup de faiblesses et on les
constate
dans un certain nombre de domaines y
compris celui des technologies ou encore
une fois elle est dépendante de
l'étranger
alors actuellement on assiste à un
ralentissement économique mondial qui
est bien évidemment lié à sa crise
sanitaire
peut-il enrayer la reprise économique
chinoise
bien sûr bien sûr fait le grand jeu
parce que la chine peut produire mais il
ressort qu'à l'export pour qu'elles
exportent il faut que tous les systèmes
de communication soit route il faut
aussi qu'elles fassent en sorte que les
barrières je dirais psychologique qui
survit en particulier au leadership
américain
selon ce qui va sortir de l'élection
américaine que ces barrières
psychologiques l'image de la chine s'il
était renforcée sous certains aspects a
été dégradée aussi les différents
sondages qui vient d'être publié en
partie des parts ou institute qui il a
brillé w lorsque l'image de la chine
loin d'être améliorée s'est dégradée
parce que elle a effectivement sur jouer
d'une certaine façon la la la la la
victoire sur l'épidémie en dénigrant
parfois ses partenaires dernière
question c'est qu'il y avait énormément
de deux puissances occidentales qui
produisent en chine certaines puissances
ont même annoncé le rapatriement de
leurs productions
est-ce selon vous un coup de bluff
devrait annoncer quelles conséquences
pour pékin c'est très concluant fait que
ce sont des situations au cas par cas la
tendance
certainement la volonté certainement et
solent ensuite ça n'est pas du jour au
lendemain que l'on démonte une usine clé
les villes stratégiques dans un
dispositif mondial les pays proches de
la chine peuvent le faire l'accord et la
fed le chapon le fait certains
relocalise en asie du sud-est pour
quitter la chine c'est facile quand on
est dans la région c'est beaucoup plus
difficile quand on a mis beaucoup
d'investissements très loin pour se
projeter et conquérir les marchés
asiatiques
à commencer par le marché chinois
naturellement donc
ça n'est pas tout à fait un coup de
bluff n'avait pas tout à fait la réalité
et c'est surtout quelque chose qui se
décline au cas par cas selon les
sociétés et les productions concernées
merci beaucoup françois d'emilio d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'institut de
recherche et ja center